avec nous il y à aussi pdg de l'institut
du québec bonsoy miami 6 bonsoir
alors encore une augmentation du nombre
de postes vacants et c'est le québec qui
enregistre la plus forte hausse est ce
que la crise pour vous est de plus en
plus aigus mais en fait on le voit venir
depuis longtemps ces enjeux-là de main
d'oeuvre on le sait que les postes
vacants
elles sont en augmentation vont
continuer de l'être
probablement c'est tout à fait normal il
ya plus de personnes qui sortent du
marché du travail qui rentrent donc à
cause notre démographie surtout hors de
montréal l'enjeu est beaucoup plus
criant est ce qui se passe par exemple
qui est particulier c'est que il ya
quand même plus de chômeurs aussi dans
certains secteurs et plus de postes
vacants dans d'autres donc il ya comme
un déséquilibre si on veut qui est
temporaire il faudra voir dans font ce
qu'il faut suivre de façon très
attentive
c est ce que c'est quelque chose qui va
se cristalliser où ça va se replacer les
choses vont se replacer au fur et à
mesure de déconfinement parce que l'on
parle des postes vacants pour le premier
trimestre donc de 2021
donc c'est pas exactement maintenant il
ya un décalage dans le temps pour les
donner mais faudra le suivre au cours
des prochains mois quand on regarde le
graphique pour le québec
on voit quand même que d'année en année
de 1er trimestre en premier trimestre on
a devancé à gauche 2017 18 19 20 21
on est toujours croissant du nombre de
postes vacants
il ya une tendance quand même à la
dégradation de la situation mais oui
puis en fait c'est la même chose peu
importe l'indicateur qu'on regarde donc
on regarde le nombre absolu on voit que
ça augmente le sait relativement stable
depuis trimestre précédent mais sur un
an ça augmente et même quand on regarde
le taux de postes vacants dont que ce
soit le nombre de postes vacants ou le
tout ça veut dire en proportion la
demande totale donc de l'emploi total
ça augmente et c'est que dans ce secteur
certains secteurs qu'on regarde les
chômeurs disponibles ou les personnes
disponibles pour combler ces postes le
sait que des fois c'est très très très
faible dans certains cas comme l'a senti
inférieur à un majeur absolument c'est
important donc santé
assistance sociale particulièrement des
infirmières des aides soignantes des
préposés aux bénéficiaires
les besoins sont grands exactement ce
qui est intéressant dans les données
qu'on a vu ce matin c'est que
l'augmentation des postes vacants sur un
an est très ciblé dans trois secteurs
santé et l'assistance sociale
construction et fabrication et dans la
fabrication c'était vraiment dans la
fabrication d'aliments est donc on
essaie de voir un peu qu'est ce qui fait
que des déséquilibres dans le marché du
travail puisque est intéressant les
textes et des secteurs où est ce que il
ya des normes de la formation il ya des
règles institutionnelles ou des
conditions salariales qui sont peut-être
plus attrayante et les gens veulent
juste pas y aller comme dans la
fabrication d'aliments t majeur pour les
prochaines étapes on veut qu'on va vivre
au niveau de la main d'oeuvre pour se
poser des questions sur ses rigidités là
parlons des solutions études de la bmo
de la fédération des chambres de
commerce du québec qui dit qu'une partie
de la solution passe par les autochtones
par les premières nations
est ce que c'est de la pensée magique
j'ose dire ça de penser qu'on va régler
nos problèmes de main d'oeuvre en
décidant que c'est soit les chômeurs qui
vont combler les postes les personnes
handicapées les gens des communautés
autochtones mais moi je pense qu'on n'a
pas le choix de regarder ses avenues le
centre dire que ça va régler tous les
problèmes parce que ce défaut lors quand
on regarde le volume c'est souvent des
très petits volumes étaient quelques
milliers de personnes qui vont être dans
les populations autochtones des
personnes qui sont handicapés ou des
personnes plus marginalisés c'est pas
une panacée mais il faut vraiment
regarder ces éléments là comme les
travailleurs de 60 ans et plus le ya
peut-être plus de marge de manoeuvre
parce qu'on a un retard par rapport à
l'ontario parce que de manière générale
sont garde les femmes les 25-54 ans on y
très avancés ou québec qu'on regarde le
taux d'activité pour d'emplois il n'y a
pas beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre donc
on n'a pas le choix de commencer à
l'hiver essayez d'inclure des
populations plus difficiles à rejoindre
le travail difficiles devant nous on ne
fait ligue 1 plus facile oui hélas
l'étude donc propose de favoriser
l'embauché de travailleurs autochtones
par des mesures incitatives et on dit on
parle de crédit d'impôt et des stars
âge notamment qu'on devrait axer sur les
stars juste que ce serait une bonne
approche
mais moi je pense que oui justement
parce que c'est des personnes qui sont
pas sur le marché du travail en ce
moment parce que lyon probablement pas
les qualifications requises dans
certains cas il faut changer certaines
habitudes qu'on a par rapport à quand on
regarde les possibilités d'embauché
peut-être que c'est des groupes qu'on
compte que les entreprises considèrent
pas je préfère qu'on mette des
ressources publiques puis du temple de
l'énergie pour essayer d'intégrer des
nouvelles personnes que d'annoncer des
nouveaux projets à coup de subventions
pour créer qu'on annonce la création
d'emplois que c'était juste des
placements d'emploi de notre prise à une
autre mettons l'argent puis l'énergie au
moins attirer des nouvelles personnes
sur le marché du travail absolument très
intéressant un dernier point sur
l'immigration est-ce que l'immigration
peut combler et là je vais vous demander
un chiffre 20 30 50 % des besoins de
main d'oeuvre mais l'immigration si on
regarde les projections d'emploi québec
le sur dix ans et 1.4 millions qu'on a
deux personnes qui vont devoir remplacer
les départs à la retraite combler les
nouveaux besoins et on estime que c'est
à peu près 22 % de ses besoins là qui
vont être comblés par l'immigration
souhaite à peu près 30 1000 par année
c'est les immigrants économiques ça
donne un ordre de grandeur le sera peut
être un peu plus un peu moins selon les
efforts qu'on fait pour le mieux les
intégrer ou selon les seuils annuels
mais je dirais que c'est entre 20 et 25%
parfait c'est clair ça merci beaucoup
mieux comme si merci à vous pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh